[Music]
all right yeah we're back once again
it's too [ __ ] sunny in here i can't
stand it yeah
[Laughter]
i need butts i need black blinds i need
blackout blinds i want to like staple
curtains across the [ __ ] and keep the
[ __ ] sun from coming in
all right so
um
yeah i want to like okay so we have like
some stuff we want to do but i want to
do that at the end okay what i mean so
at least we can talk about the movie
first on my packages and stuff yeah yeah
yeah you don't want to miss saying that
for a main show because i don't think
she's in here should we we'll see well
maybe we can do it and then like we can
do it again like on the wednesday show
okay you know what i'm saying all right
but we'll talk about the movie first
because this is like a movie review
right and i'm sure everyone is just
waiting on baited breath
for what we think about dark matter dark
man too well yeah we've been doing the
dark man trilogy we watched the first
dark man we reviewed that yesterday
we're gonna watch part three tonight and
talk about that tomorrow
so uh so what do we think of this one
yeah it was a good movie i actually
didn't mind it yeah the only thing that
was different was uh
liam neeson wasn't in it but other than
that the guy who replaced him was pretty
good too you know it's still a good
movie
it doesn't have um
the more comic book element it doesn't
have kind of like that sam raimi kind of
energy to it it's kind of more a
straightforward
uh kind of like crime thriller a little
more sedate
yeah it doesn't have kind of like like i
said that that extra energy to it but
all that said
i actually didn't really mind it it does
seem like i don't know i kind of feel
like even among people that like dark
man
most people are kind of like yeah the
first one's really good the second one's
like kind of fair to middling and then
the third one is just kind of
bad but
well interestingly though and i didn't
know this until i read the wikipedia
page but this one
was actually shot after the third one
okay but for whatever reason they
released this one first this one came
out in 95
and then i think this third one came out
in 96 like the following year these were
directed
to video these didn't go like to the
theater or anything yeah they're asking
me my opinion on the [ __ ] slapping
incident we'll talk i'll talk about the
slap and that's the at the end of the
show
and uh just remind me
the will smith slap
yeah i heard about it i just i don't
know i saw it i didn't care to read
about it yeah it's because everybody's
talking because i don't care everybody's
talking so i didn't bother i'll talk
about it at the end of the show but
anyway um
yeah like i said i don't care about it
so it's like i didn't i didn't bother
yeah um
i'd find better things to do but uh yeah
so uh this was directed by bradford may
now sam raimi actually was the uh the
executive producer on it
and
as we said on yesterday's show liam
neeson
didn't come back for this one so they
got a different actor
uh arnold vaslu and like the whole time
i'm watching it and i'm just like man
where do i know that guy from and like
have i seen that dude and other [ __ ] or
is it just because he looks exactly like
billy zane and i'm thinking of billy
zane
but now
he does look a lot like billy zane i'm
just saying i'm just gonna say but i did
recognize him you know where i recognize
him from the mummy the brendan fraser
ones from the 90s he played imhotep
in those movies so i was like oh okay
that's where i recognize it i didn't see
those he was in oh they're good you
probably like them but um they're a lot
more fun than that tom cruise
abomination oh man stop talking
no those mummy ones are actually fun
like the brandon fraser they're more
like indiana jones he was in blood
diamond too uh arnold bosley which was
actually a really good movie just to be
[ __ ] contrary i had to go out and buy
the mummy tom cruise mommy on blu-ray
why would that be contrary to me it's
like nobody else likes it well a lot of
people like it really he thinks he's
going to own me by saying put his money
on it and everybody's like okay i'm just
saying being conscious so buy it if you
like it i know no one cares
i hope there's a longer director cut an
extended cut
it's not a terrible movie i just didn't
think there was anything special about
it i just i didn't like what they did
with it but like i said they cut it down
so much none of the there were all these
characters and none of them had big
parts that was part of the problem i
mean but you know we've talked about
that movie a lot and it's just kind of
like i'm
you know um but yeah so what what they
did with this movie
so
i told you yesterday i was like now
seeing the end of the first dark man
where
durant played by larry drake
uh pretty definitively died at the end
of the first one i mean it would be
really hard for anybody to survive that
like he's basically he's in a helicopter
and it smashes into like an underpass
and explodes and goes into his like
gazillion pieces uh so yeah so then i
see the second one is called the return
of durant and i'm like yeah that's a
trick i'd like to see but
okay so at first i was just kind of like
okay well they didn't even like explain
how he could have survived that
helicopter crash basically they just had
a line in there where two of his thugs
are like i don't know how anybody could
have survived a crash like that i'm like
you want me both pal
i don't know either um but they didn't
like explain like any rape but so he's
been in a coma for
however long since the last movie so
like four years or whatever
and then he finally wakes up from the
coma i kind of think i i wish
that they would have made him look like
kind of a little [ __ ] up i mean he's
got like a scar
on his forehead like a very minor scar i
know it's been a few years and he kind
of has a thing where oh and he has to
like take pills all the time like he's
in pain like he's all internal injuries
or whatever but other than that he looks
totally fine he should have given him
superpower
like some kind of superpower well i
thought else how else could he have
survived that's what i mean i kind of
thought they were maybe gonna
i don't know but then like as the movie
went on because i will say that this
movie i'm actually glad that they call
it the return of durant because it
mostly i mean dark man's in it obviously
but it kind of focuses more on the
villain
and i'm okay with that
thank you high ice 07 007 one of the
best chase scenes in movie history
uh police a as350 helicopter chasing a
belgian ranger helicopter yeah that was
in the first one was it not uh because
there wasn't a helicopter chase in this
one was there i don't think so no i feel
like there wasn't yeah the first one
actually does have an amazing helicopter
jace in it but this one i mean if you
have larry drake
he is just such a good bad guy so i
think it was the right decision to just
be like [ __ ] it he survived you know
let's move on and uh
and then he is mostly like the focus of
this movie and the plot of it is pretty
similar to the first one in the sense
that
you know durant and his thugs are kind
of like this time instead of wanting to
get like a memo
they
want to buy this building because it's
like an old
electrical like factory or power works
or something and they want to make like
all these super weapons
and so they bust doc brown out of
hannibal lecter jail
and have him make it you know what i
mean like it's a pot what is it it's a
ghostbusters gun essentially it's like a
positive glider man that's like
the ray even was like a rope that went
like that yeah yeah yeah yeah there was
some corny [ __ ] in the movie with but
hey it's dark man
yeah i actually didn't mind it i didn't
abide it they were in the early on they
were like hey if we can make some new
assault rifles then we can take over the
world uh yeah
that's what every army might think and
none of you nobody's ever seen no one's
been able to take over the world with
assault rifles well i mean nobody said
that these criminals were like super
smart but the thing about it is that
well at least they had the right idea
like we're basically making death rays
is what they were trying to make um
which that's a better idea yeah i really
did like there was one fight like toward
the end where they were like shooting at
each other and like one like kind of got
knocked up over it like not shot through
the ceiling and i said you know how
funny would it have been if they like
disintegrated the moon
and they'll be like oh [ __ ] look what we
did but yeah because these guns were
like
i mean they could disintegrate [ __ ] like
a long time away but there's like there
was a couple dumb lines in it too
because
they had a test for this senator
congressperson whoever the [ __ ] he was
that was buying them from the from the
evil guys
and so they blow up
uh like an oil tanker
and it pretty it was it went like kind
of melty and then it like exploded real
good
and then like one of the other guys like
one of his henchmen says if it can do
that to an oil tanker or whatever what
would it do to a person i'm like what do
you think i'm like if they could like
blow up a [ __ ]
oil tanker from that far away
i mean it's gonna turn a person into
like a [ __ ] crimson spray is that's
what's gonna happen just use your
imagination but yeah basically they're
talking about the [ __ ] weirding
modules from from dune yeah that's what
the weirding modules would do just blow
up anything
all you do is just say word
but the reason i said before i mean the
guy the scientist that they busted out
of jail
um or it was a psychiatric hospital like
i said that's why i said it was hannibal
elect or jail because it looked like the
hannibal lecter cell
and they busted him out to make this uh
to make this death ray essentially and
he was uh really christopher lloyd in
the [ __ ] out i mean big time but i think
that was deliberate i mean he wasn't
going as far over the top as christopher
lloyd but you could tell that he was
homaging that performance but yeah so
so the whole thing like the thugs want
this factory and it so happens that
working in this factory is another
scientist
who
was working on the same [ __ ] that dark
man is working on like the whole uh the
whole skin regeneration skin grafting
thing
and he's actually figured out
how to solve the photo sensitivity
problem
so dark man sees an article about him in
a magazine and like goes and they're
gonna partner up but because he's at
this factory that the gang needs
they and they offer to buy it at first
so that's nice um but you know obviously
the scientist says no so he's like he
tortures and kills him and then dark man
like incurs the wrath they figure out
because everybody thinks that durant is
dead
um but dark man figures out that he's
still alive and he has to prove he's
still live and then there's like a
newscaster and stuff like that so like i
said it's like a similar plot to the
first one it's not quite as
like fun
i guess because it doesn't have that sam
raimi kind of
little edge of wackiness to it like that
comic book sensibility
but it was still a pretty solid
like action thriller i mean i wasn't
i've seen some other reviews of it like
i said which seemed pretty mixed like
some people just thought it was dumb
like the acting was bad i didn't think
that at all
um
i actually thought that um
that uh arnold vossly made a decent dark
man i mean he's not
i don't know he's not um i guess as
charismatic as liam neeson was you know
he's a little more subdued but you know
let's be honest liam neeson in dark man
that was the beginning of his career
nobody knew who he was he wasn't this
charismatic as you're thinking he was
charismatic retroactively
on the back of all those well he did
later i mean that i mean charismatic in
this he was kind of like
he was kind of weird in that role he was
he was it really should have been sam
raimi
bruce campbell bruce campbell i mean
yeah
she had been bruce campbell i mean i
would have liked to have seen you know
no shade on liam neeson like i said but
i really would have liked to have seen
bruce campbell in that yeah
um i was thinking bruce campbell's
[ __ ] he was the other guy was the uh
sam raymond was the famous director
right but bruce campbell they just
thought that he wasn't a big enough name
sadly that's ridiculous he which is
ridiculous he'd have been great well i
mean in hindsight it's ridiculous
because it's like well i kind of feel
like bruce campbell he just i feel like
he just never got
i mean he's been in a ton of [ __ ] yeah
um and he seems like a lovely person he
shows up at all the cons and everything
like that but i i just feel like he's
now he never got as famous as he should
have i kind of feel the same way about
like jeffrey combs
and uh you know actors like that where
they didn't really brad doroth like they
never really get the recognition that
they deserve except in the horror
community where they're like pretty much
universally beloved yeah but they never
really kind of broke through to
mainstream audiences and more than like
a
few kind of like a sideline character
look at if you look at his liam neeson's
performance it's bruce campbell he's
doing he's doing a lot of bruce campbell
impressions sometimes it's like a little
bit everybody's going crazy
and talking about the cat talking to the
cat and dancing
his voice it sounds like he's doing a
little bit
like he's doing um
uh [ __ ] bruce campbell a little bit
it does kind of yeah yeah now that i'm
thinking about it i think they i think
well he did well bruce campbell did do
some overdubs on the voices so some of
it actually might be him might be him
talking
because he did say that he did some of
the overdoses what it is he's like
especially sounds real schizo yeah
because he especially like when there
was like some kind of like emoting he
said you know that one scene like in the
first one i'm talking about now the
first dark man where he's uh he's just
come out of the thing and he's all
[ __ ] up and he sees uh julie like his
girlfriend and he's going to say joel
hey julie yeah that's bruce campbell's
okay
that's right that's probably why i'm
saying that he did do some overdubs for
it which actually i didn't know until i
was like researching it but yeah yeah um
so yeah so this one you know it's not as
good as the first one but i thought it
was still worth watching because i think
it was a good idea to focus on the
villain even though in real life there's
no way that he could have survived that
[ __ ] helicopter crash carrying the
movie but he's so good in it that i was
like you know what i'm not even mad at
it not mad at it i mean because larry
drake is just so entertaining to watch
and like i said i didn't really mind
like the new guy being dark man
even though the story's not super
focused on him
i was comparing dark man 1 to kind of
like robocop
all right dark man 2 was kind of like
robocop too they're both good
there were differences you know what i
mean but they were both pretty good
yeah you know and i mean you know like i
said this one's worth watching i i kind
of hope the third one's not terrible but
we're going to watch the third one
tonight and see how that goes sad as
robocop 3. i don't even remember robocop
because
although i have heard there was a bunch
of [ __ ] that got cut out of robocop
three and there have been some fan edits
to try to put robo three corrobor cop
three back there it's time to be alive
i said what a time to be alive i was
like all this technology is so cheap
that it's like i don't even i don't like
this big hollywood movie i'm going to
make my own version yeah at home
yeah i just heard i just read that
though in a forum i've never seen it and
you know sometimes you read things and
it's [ __ ] yeah but evidently there's
a robocop 3 edit out there that's
supposed to be a lot better than that
i'm sure there's fan edits of a lot of
movies that are kind of
that that people kind of wish were
better
you know what i mean
lee warner says so you have peter murphy
nick cave robert smith and andrew
eldridge on a desert island you have no
food which one do you kill first peter
murphy
well actually okay let's let's look at
this from from a from a practical
standpoint robert smith probably has the
most uh
nice fat on him yeah but he's probably
the nicest guy but he might be the
nicest one now so
so i don't know it might be between if
if we're going by fat content then yeah
it'd probably be robert smith but if
we're going by
insufferable content then it'd probably
be either peter murphy or andrew
eldritch like who are you going to get
sick of peter murphy would go for
quenching first peter murphy's first you
know what i mean who's like insufferable
first and we're gonna like get rid of
him peter murphy should not be allowed
on stage not anymore not in his
condition nick cave is a delight so i
would save him until last right
[Laughter]
he's pretty scrawny peter murphy attacks
the [ __ ] audience gets thrown out of
his own events
he got booted out of his own throne
what happened to him he's a [ __ ] dick
he's a real dick he really kind of went
on the downward uh slide there
i haven't kept up with him lately but i
haven't even didn't dj maniac said that
bauhaus did a new song like an exquisite
corpse type thing but i forgot and i
didn't like listen he flees the scenes
of [ __ ] accidents and [ __ ] [ __ ]
these
and he's even doing the oh those aren't
my drugs though yeah right yeah come on
no yes that's that's not my crack
[Laughter]
who put that there put all that crap
all that mess there huh
in my body
who put that crack in my mouth
[Laughter]
eldritch is an [ __ ] too okay that's
what i'm saying which one would i get
sick of he's just talking first he's a
different kind of [ __ ] though he
thinks he knows better than his fans
he's the guy who does not want to give
the fans what which again that is that
makes you an [ __ ] he seems very
uh condescending like every even back in
the day when i used to see interviews
with him like he's very intelligent
clearly but uh he's one of those people
that's really intelligent and like knows
it and is like lording it over on you
and he just comes across as very like
imperious he lowers himself to speak to
you right it does he does kind of seem
like and then he [ __ ] makes fun of
his fans and you know well
they're americans
yeah
okay he's just
he's a [ __ ] dick all right and uh
the best thing about sisters of earth
mercy where it was wayne hussey and
[ __ ] the band that ended up being
[ __ ]
uh mission uk that was the best part of
assistance of mercy
um
well i mean after the first album that
wayne hussey was on like after i mean
and after the first time when they did
then they kind of went in a more like
metal direction yeah or glam direction
yeah now i'm not going to say that
[ __ ]
sister's mercy after that wasn't any
good it was it was good [ __ ] um
floodline was pretty good even though
there was no tour for that and [ __ ]
patricia morrison wasn't wasn't on that
album she was just in the video she
didn't even tour
and um
vision thing was okay it was good but
those were me that was a metal album
yeah
that was trying to go very la
but then you look at mission and mission
went on to do a bunch of cool [ __ ]
that first that first album that they
did the white one what was it called
that had [ __ ] dancing barefoot on it
and had [ __ ] um
oh man what's the name of that
mission album
uh don't matter just a white album with
red writing on it it's almost as good as
[ __ ] first and lasted always i just i
just don't own it you know but i used to
[ __ ] really listen to it i don't own
it anymore
jason he be dead says i liked seeing
vaslu in the in these films because i've
been enjoying him in the mummy films so
it seemed kind of similar i was so glad
that i was like because i was like it
was i was like i know that's not billy
zane i was like but is it just because
he looks like billy zane and i just
watched like tales from the crypt demon
night which had billy zane in it i'm
like am i just thinking of that but so i
was like really glad when i was like oh
okay thank god it was like he he wasn't
the mummy so i did recognize him from
that jason says will you guys review gi
jane oh they're [ __ ] with me
okay okay i'll tell you about the
slapping all right wait a minute wait a
minute jenny doesn't know what we're
talking about well i do i just didn't
read about it because i don't care
i saw a headline and i was just like
whatever
i guess jenny doesn't want me to talk
about it so
well no i don't care i just said i i
can't contribute because i don't really
um but no was it real i think it was
staged all right i don't think anybody
watches the oscars anymore and i think
will smith wanted people to see him get
the oscar so he [ __ ] slapped he
slapped chris [ __ ] chris tucker in
the face over a gi jane joke because his
wife had alopecia
which jada pika smith's [ __ ] gorgeous
woman yeah she's she's she's totally
bald now and she got a little thing that
looks like a scar on top of her head big
[ __ ] deal hey she was entails from
the crypt demon night too yeah she looks
she looks [ __ ] great you know
me a lot of black girls we a friend of
ours crystal is [ __ ] tall
skinny
girl that works at [ __ ] black girl
that works at universal studios and she
dresses up as you know she's one of the
storms she actually thinks she does
storm she does a bunch of other stuff
now she's working with disney's one of
the jedi's and [ __ ] she looks gorgeous
um bald
some women look really good bald and and
jada's lucky that she looks really good
bald
you always put a wig on
but he made that thing and [ __ ] will
smith gets up and [ __ ]
slaps him in the [ __ ] face in front
of everybody tucker did
look like he was [ __ ] shocked
but i don't know both of those guys are
actors they may have pulled that off you
know and try to make it look
uncomfortable because that was the best
television in [ __ ] years
and now everybody's talking about it and
they don't talk about the oscars anymore
see it could have been a setup
could have been
well wasn't it just kind of like that
super bowl thing where who was it justin
timberlake tearing the titty thing off
of janet jackson was it justin
timberlake that was like i don't know a
long time ago like i don't watch that
either but
i just remember i don't know it's like i
don't well that was i don't really care
that was staged it's just that people
reacted to it as if it wasn't
but yeah that's what i mean but like i
said it's you know they're gonna do
something like controversy like you said
you know because nobody was
nobody was watching this [ __ ] so
uh
i watched the body language [ __ ] when
he said the g.i jane thing it looked
like will smith was laughing along with
it for a second and then it
and then
um and then he noticed that his wife
[ __ ] was uh not happy about it so
then he says well i have to do something
so he
bows up and goes up there and [ __ ]
slaps him now there's a pro wrestler
look at it and said it looked like he
pulled the slap
at the end
so it might have been ad-libbed but it
was probably that they may have [ __ ]
had it
had a plan to cause a ruckus you know
maybe
it's it's
plausible but you know and some people
were saying well it's because they have
an open relationship and [ __ ] will
smith felt played and you know been
because he's a [ __ ] and this and that's
not what it is
will smith and [ __ ] jade are there
those two are alpha as [ __ ] they're
they're not going anywhere they got all
kinds of money and they they date other
people that
you know that's never really been
explained what it was you know maybe
they can just date people they're
probably dating people they know
or i don't know if they're [ __ ]
having threesomes and [ __ ] but whatever
it is they're they're they're down for
it it doesn't mean he's a cuck
you know you know what i mean just
people take [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
proportion
they take [ __ ] and run with it
uh yeah i guess so
um but yeah oh one thing i wanted to say
too was that
one absolutely awesome thing that i
think i'm going to make a shirt from
is in dark man 2
is that durant larry break larry drake
um the girl like the sister of the
scientist that gets killed she like
pulls a gun and like tries to shoot him
and he says he calls her a ridiculous
[ __ ] and i said
oh my god i'm making a shirt that says
ridiculous [ __ ] on it and i'm totally
gonna wear it too
[Laughter]
all right so
um i don't think tammy is here
but i wanted to show this anyway we'll
probably show it again on um the main
show like on wednesday when she is here
but i just wanted to say because we got
this today so tammy sent us this box we
just got it
and
i'll wait until she's here like to read
the card and stuff because she sent us a
little card that would like that was
really sweet and also look at this she
sent pookie some
temptations she said for pookie she's
the real star of the show which that's
that's true
also
crunchy cookie butter yeah i've never
had cookie i don't think i've ever had
this before i've had these i've had
these
these cookies before but i've never had
the cookie butter no it's funny where's
sandra been
oh
girl she got abducted oh my god maybe
she did
and look duck
chunky
yeah she gave those to me big old three
i didn't think they made these anymore i
remembered these from my childhood and i
was like holy crap i haven't seen one of
those in a really long time those things
those things must be special order maybe
they are let me see the mouse things are
bigger than i remember yeah well no i
think that's the same size and look she
sent me some lint uh these like kind of
lindor truffles and they're white
chocolate which is my favorite i [ __ ]
love this so if you're out there tammy
thank you i'm going to show this stuff
again if if any of this food is still
left which is they came in a six-piece
share pack so i get it oh this is the
raisin ones peanuts they all they always
have raisins they always had raisins
i thought they were just chocolate no
they also no they always have raisins in
them you'll see i remember i'll eat them
on the show big old thick chocolate bars
yeah he's going to chew like really loud
i'd be like
[Laughter]
he's going to do like chewing asmr hey
some people are into that you know
remember the hundred thousand dollar bar
yeah they had to change them to a
hundred grand bar because there's some
people that couldn't read the numbers
that's like that's too many zeros
there's [ __ ] bits 10 200
i understand that it's making me mad
yeah well i was just i was really good i
was reading an article yesterday i think
it was from i think it was a repost from
a year or two ago but it was like the
most underrated candies and maybe they
still make those because i'm pretty sure
somebody like a couple people put a
hundred grand bar in there yeah it was
good so maybe they still make those
all it was is it was a damn bar of um
caramel rolled in
reese's peanut
crispy know what they call rice krispies
yeah and then and then chocolate
that's all it was they were good real
good well hey man sometimes it's simple
i did like that on the list the payday
bar was on there because i feel i'm
going to represent for the payday bar oh
henry bar those are good too
yeah remember those
yeah remember the reggie bar
that i do not remember yeah reggie
jackson he was a baseball bat well i
know i know who reggie was it was a
round patty and it was like a turtle it
was just caramel with uh i think it was
i think it was nuts of some sort
and then just with chocolate on it i
think it might have been um
a lot of pecans
or nuts turtles were one of my grandma's
favorite they're good though i mean
remember they came in like that pink
that pink and green straight box they
made them yeah and uh yeah you'd make
them sometimes her
she loved turtles and she loved uh
chocolate covered cherries about
prolines man yeah remember those
but i was yeah sugar candy i mean the
thing that i was like that i was reading
was like stuff that you could buy in the
store nobody put the zero bar there oh
those are good i love zero and then
there was that one called a nuno
i kind of remember those i don't think
they make they were similar to zero
they're a white chocolate bar yeah
zeros you can still get those because
i've seen those um i saw those in
dollar general or in publix like just
last week i think it's like a albino
snickers
it's an alpine stickers
essentially yeah it's like white
chocolate with like nougat yeah it's not
as it's harder though it's not as like
smooshy no which is which is better
because snickers when i get it i like
snickers but i like them better when
they're frozen and it had almonds
instead of peanuts i think i yeah i
think you're right i haven't had one in
a while i used to this where i used to
work like a long time ago every now and
then somebody that would come to stock
the snack machine would put zero bars in
there like once every
six or eight months or something and
then i would get all excited and i think
i was probably the only one that ate
them but yeah
but yeah i get them in the store every
now and then but
yeah so uh anyway what were you talking
about no no nothing
like usual but yeah dark man 2 not as
bad as you might be thinking it was
actually pretty good yeah it was good it
was better than i was expecting it to be
we're going to see what three is and
tonight we're going to watch three and
see how that goes down three times is a
charm
well like i said superman well like i
said the third one was supposedly shot
before this one yeah so i'm guessing
larry drake is not in this one yeah it's
not in the third one yeah um but arnold
vossly is still dark man yeah so i have
no idea what the story is going to be
because i don't i didn't read anything
about it but
if it's got a 3 on it a lot of times
it's bad
superman 3 was terrible
uh well i think superman 4 was better
than superman 3.
oh now let's not go i don't know man
let's not go that far superman four was
at least a [ __ ] trip hey nightmare at
elm street three was good was it okay
yeah dream warriors
friday the 13th part three was good
not as good as two yeah it was still
good i didn't like part three yeah
friday the 13th but nightmare now
yeah
look at my yo-yo yeah
stop it there's never anything like
titties or anything
there's always like some kind of you
would think that would be like that's
what they would put yeah you would think
that that would be like the whole reason
yeah they had some they had some [ __ ]
very well endowed yeah it's like one of
them titties they're
earlier
eyeballs at you spears coming at you and
put them in there it's all good yeah you
could just have the whole movie like
you you'd have a whole bunch of teenage
boys in there watching that you got a
boob then an eyeball i knew what they
were doing then another boob then a
spleen yeah it could have been a whole
thing yeah oh well
yeah exorcist three yeah there you go
yeah pretty good yeah that was also very
good that was that's what did we talk
about
that was really good omen three is
pretty good too
so it's not yeah i mean usually yeah
once they get to the third one you're
just kind of like all right yeah but
sometimes
although i'll say that exorcist three i
think the reason that that's good is
because it went like in a little bit of
a
side like a little bit of a side swipe
like a little bit of a different it's
not a different genre exactly but they
did a little bit of a different thing
with it so i think that was a good idea
evil dead three there you go also
another good one so yeah lots of star
wars three
yeah there's lots of good ones yeah lots
of good ones yeah so you don't know what
you're talking about
those are the exceptions to the rules
toy story three yeah all the time
honestly all the toy story movies are
good gonna not gonna lie
uh but yeah so dark man two it's on
shutter uh all three of them are on
there so if you have shutter you can
watch along we're gonna watch three
tonight and see how that goes and we'll
talk about that one tomorrow so thanks
for coming by thanks for hanging out
thanks for super chats and we will be
back again tomorrow evening
bye